[Music]
where does ISIL
find its funding the militants who've
recently ransacked large parts of the
Middle East for themselves the Islamic
State of Iraq and the Levant ISIL for
short President Obama calls them
jihadists the organization's been active
in Syria and Iraq for several years but
it's only struck at rich recently after
seizing Iraq's largest northern city
Mosul fighters of ransacked cash
reserves across the region but it's a
challenge to ascertain the amounts
involved one widely circulated report
quotes a local governor is saying that
Mosel central bank lost four hundred and
twenty nine million dollars if true this
would put ISIL in the moneyed militant
major leagues alongside the Afghan
Taliban and Colombia's FARC but
separately ISIL already controls oil and
gas facilities in parts of neighboring
Syria allowing it to power its military
machine and profit from black market
sales Syria's pre-conflict oil
production was around 400,000 barrels a
day by the side of this year that had
dropped 25,000 further funding has
funneled to Syrian rebel factions from
wealthy donors in Gulf states like
Kuwait Qatar Saudi Arabia relatively few
of those donors say they send it to
extreme groups like ISIL intentionally
at least and finally just to make
matters murkier some rival rebel groups
have claimed ISIL members receive
reimbursements from Syrian and Iranian
intelligence agencies and the group's
leader Abu Bakr al Baghdadi is also
considered valuable by the US government
dead or alive there's currently a 10
million dollar bounty on his head